y cientos de miles más en todo el mundo,
en Columbus, Georgia, en Cardiff, Gales,
en Chongqing, China, en Madrás, India,
saldrán de sus casas,
se subirán a sus autos o usarán el transporte público
o irán a pie,
entrarán en una sala,
se sentarán junto a alguien que no conocen,
o quizás si lo conozcan,
se apagarán las luces y verán una película.
Verán películas sobre aliens o robots
o aliens robots o gente normal.
Pero todas serán películas sobre qué significa ser humano.
Millones sentirán asombro o miedo,
millones se reirán y millones llorarán.
Y luego las luces volverán a encenderse
y volverán al mundo que conocían hacía unas horas.
Y millones de personas verán el mundo
un poco distinto de como lo hacían cuando entraron.
Como ir al templo o a la mezquita o a la iglesia,
o a cualquier otra institución religiosa,
ir al cine, de muchas maneras, es un ritual sagrado.
Que se repite semana tras semana tras semana.
Yo iré este fin de semana,
igual que hecho casi todos los fines de semanas entre 1996 y 1990,
al multicine, cerca del centro comercial
a unos 8 km. de la casa de mi infancia en Columbus, Georgia.
Lo curioso es que en algún momento entre entonces y ahora
cambié accidentalmente parte de la conversación
sobre cuáles de esas películas se llegan a hacer.
La historia comienza en 2005, en un despacho en lo alto de Sunset Boulevard,
donde era un joven ejecutivo
en Appian Way, la productora de Leonardo DiCaprio.
Y para aquellos que no sepan cómo funciona la industria del cine,
básicamente significa que yo era uno de las pocos detrás de la persona
que produce la película para la gente que está detrás y delante de la cámara
y cuyos nombres reconocerán mejor que el mío.
Era el ayudante del productor que hace el trabajo poco glamuroso
que conlleva el aspecto creativo de producir una película.
Se hacen listas de guionistas, directores y actores
que pueden ser adecuados para las películas que quieren hacer;
se reúnen con muchos de ellos y sus representantes,
deseando ganarse su favor para una futura cita.
Y leen mucho.
Leen novelas que pueden convertirse en películas,
cómics que pueden convertirse en películas,
artículos que pueden convertirse en películas,
guiones que pueden convertirse en películas.
Y leen guiones de escritores que puede que escriban la adaptación
de las novelas, los cómics, los artículos,
y que puede que reescriban los guiones con los que ya trabajan.
Todo con el fin de encontrar el próximo bombazo
o al próximo gran guionista que pueda ofrecer algo
que haga que Uds. o su empresa sean los próximos bombazos.
En 2005 yo era ejecutivo de desarrollo en la productora de Leonardo.
Recibí una llamada del representante de un guionista
que empezó casi igual que todo ese tipo de conversaciones:
"Tengo la próxima película de Leo".
En la película que su cliente había escrito,
Leo interpretaría a un miembro de la industria del petróleo
cuya novia, una meteoróloga local, amenaza con dejarle
porque su trabajo contribuye al calentamiento global.
Y está situación es relevante
porque hay un huracán en el Atlántico
que amenaza con causar un daño similar al de Maria desde Maine hasta Myrtle Beach.
Leo, muy triste por la posible ruptura,
investiga un poco sobre el huracán
y descubre que en su camino sobre el Atlántico,
pasará por un volcán que lleva tiempo inactivo pero que ahora está activo
y que lanzará ceniza tóxica al ojo del huracán
lo que lo convertirá en un tipo de arma química
que destruirá el mundo.
(Risas)
Llegados a ese punto le pregunté:
"¿Me estás intentando colar 'Leo contra la supertormenta tóxica
que destruirá la humanidad?'"
Y como respuesta me dijo:
"Bueno, si lo dices así suena ridículo".
Y me avergüenza admitir que le permití que me enviara el guion
y que leí 30 páginas para asegurarme de que era tan malo como pensaba.
"Supertormenta" es un ejemplo extremo
pero tampoco es un ejemplo infrecuente.
Y desgraciadamente no todos los guiones se rechazan con tanta facilidad.
Por ejemplo, una comedia sobre una chica en el último curso de instituto
que al enfrentarse a un embarazo no deseado
toma una decisión inusual respecto a su futuro hijo.
Claramente es "Juno".
USD 230 millones en la taquilla mundial,
cuatro nominaciones a los Oscars, una victoria.
¿Y qué hay del adolescente de Bombay que creció entre chabolas
y que quiere participar en la versión india
de "¿Quién quiere ser millonario?"?
Esa es fácil, "Slumdog Millionaire".
USD 377 millones en todo el mundo,
10 nominaciones a los Oscars y 8 victorias.
Un chimpacé cuenta la historia
de su vida viviendo con el legendario Michael Jackson.
¿Alguien?
(Risas)
Es una pregunta trampa.
Pero es un guion llamado "Bubbles"
y va a ser dirigido por Taika Waititi,
el director de "Thor: Ragnarok".
Una gran parte del trabajo del ejecutivo de desarrollo
es separar las "Supertormentas" de los "Slumdog Millionaires",
y de manera más general los guionistas que escriben "Supertormenta"
de los que escriben "Slumdog Millionaire".
Y obviamente la manera más fácil de hacerlo es leyendo todos los guiones
pero francamente, es imposible.
Como regla general, el Sindicato de Guionistas de EE.UU.
registra unas 50 000 piezas de material cada año
y la mayoría son guiones.
De estos, unos 5000 aproximadamente
pasan varios filtros, agencias, empresas de gestión,
composición de guiones y similares
y los lee alguien de la productora
o de algún gran estudio.
Y se intenta decidir si pueden ser
una de las 300, y bajando, películas que hacen los grandes estudios
o algunos de sus asociados cada año.
Alguna vez lo he descrito
como entrar a una librería exclusiva para miembros
en la que todo el inventario está organizado de cualquier manera
y todos los libros tienen la misma portada sin descripción.
El trabajo consiste en entrar a esa librería
y no salir hasta que se encuentren los libros mejores y más rentables.
Es anárquico y alegremente opaco.
Y todos tienen un método para afrontar estos problemas.
La mayoría confía en las grandes agencias
y asumen que si hay un gran talento en el mundo,
ya ha encontrado la forma de llegar a las agencias,
sin importar las barreras estructurales que existan
para llegar hasta las agencias en primer lugar.
Otros están constantemente comparando notas entre ellos
sobre lo que han leído y lo que es bueno
y simplemente esperan que su séquito sea el mejor y más conectado
y tenga el mejor gusto en la ciudad.
Y otros tratan de leer todo pero una vez más, es imposible.
Si leen 500 guiones al año
están leyendo mucho.
Y sigue siendo un pequeño porcentaje de lo que hay.
Básicamente se usa el triaje.
Y cuando se usa el triaje se tiende a caer en la sabiduría convencional
sobre lo que funciona y lo que no.
Una comedia sobre una mujer joven que lidia con la realidad reproductiva
no vende.
La historia de un adolescente indio no es viable en el mercado doméstico
o en cualquier otro sitio fuera de India.
La única fuente de películas viables es un grupo muy reducido de guionistas
que ya se han hecho un hueco en Hollywood,
que ya tienen los mejores representantes del negocio
y que escriben una franja de historias muy limitada.
Y me da un poco de vergüenza admitir que ahí es donde yo me encontraba en 2005.
Sentado en el despacho sobre Sunset Boulevard,
mirando a esa librería anónima y metafórica
y habiendo leído guiones malos durante meses.
Y pensé que eso significaba dos cosas:
que A: no era muy bueno en mi trabajo,
que aparentemente era encontrar buenos guiones,
o B: leer guiones malos era mi trabajo.
Por eso las llamadas semanales de mi madre preguntando
si mi examen de acceso a la facultad de derecho seguía valiendo
era algo a lo que debía prestar más atención.
Lo que también sabía
era que estaba a punto de irme de vacaciones
y si leer malos guiones es malo cuando es tu trabajo,
cuando estás de vacaciones es aún peor.
Así que tenía que hacer algo.
Una noche en mi despacho hice una lista
de todos con quienes había desayunado, comido, cenado o tomado algo
y que tenían trabajos parecidos al mío y les envié un email anónimo.
Y les hice una petición muy simple.
Envíenme una lista de hasta 10 de sus guiones preferidos
que cumplan tres requisitos.
Uno: el guion les encanta,
dos: la versión cinematográfica del guion no estará en los cines
al final de ese año natural,
y tres: descubrieron ese guion este año.
Esto no era un llamada para guiones que fueran a ser los siguientes blockbusters,
ni una llamada para los que fueran a ganar el Oscar,
no tenían por qué ser guiones que sus jefes amaran
o que quisiera hacer el estudio.
Era solo una oportunidad para que la gente diera su opinión
sobre lo que les gustaba,
que, en este mundo, es cada vez más raro.
Casi todas las 75 personas a las que escribí de manera anónima respondieron.
Y luego otras dos docenas de personas escribieron al email anónimo
para poder participar,
pero confirmé que de verdad tuvieran los trabajos que decían tener.
Pasé los votos a una hoja de cálculo,
hice una tabla cruzada, lo exporté a PowerPoint
y la noche antes de irme de vacaciones
le puse un nombre casi subversivo
y se lo envié desde el email anónimo
a todos los que votaron.
La lista "negra".
Un homenaje a los que perdieron sus carreras con la histeria anticomunista
de los años 40 y 50
y una inversión consciente de la noción
de que de alguna manera negro tiene una connotación negativa.
Tras llegar a México, llevé una silla hasta la piscina,
empecé a leer los guiones y descubrí, para mi sorpresa y alegría,
que la gran mayoría eran bastante buenos.
Misión cumplida.
Lo que no hube esperado
es lo que pasó después.
Cuando llevaba cerca de una semana de vacaciones
pasé por el centro de negocios del hotel para mirar mi email.
Después de todo ese era un mundo pre iPhone.
Y descubrí que la lista que había creado de manera anónima
me la habían reenviado varias docenas de veces
a mi email personal.
Todo el mundo estaba compartiendo la lista de guiones que todos amaban,
leyéndolos y amándolos ellos también.
Y mi primera reacción, que en realidad no puedo decir aquí,
pero que la describiré como miedo,
la idea de tantear a la gente sobre los guiones
no era ni nueva ni ingeniosa.
Seguro que había alguna ley del silencio no escrita en Hollywood
que había evitado que la gente lo intentara antes
y sobre la que yo era demasiado ingenuo para conocerla,
pues estaba en el principio de mi carrera.
Estaba seguro de que me iban a despedir
así que ese día decidí que A: no contaría a nadie
que lo había hecho,
y B: nunca lo volvería a hacer.
Seis meses después pasó algo todavía más extraño.
Estaba en mi despacho, en Sunset,
y recibí una llamada del agente de otro guionista.
La llamada comenzó de manera muy similar a la llamada de "Supertormenta":
"Tengo la próxima película de Leo".
Esa no es la parte interesante.
Lo interesante fue la forma en que acabó la llamada.
Porque ese agente me dijo, y cito literal,
"No se lo digas a nadie pero sé de buena mano
que va a ser el guion número uno en la Lista negra del año que viene".
(Risas)
Sí.
No hace falta decir que me quedé a cuadros.
Tenía a una agente usando la Lista negra, que yo había hecho anónimamente,
y que decidí no volver a hacer,
para venderme a su cliente.
Sugirió que el guion tenía mérito
basándose solo en la posibilidad de ser incluído en la lista de guiones amados.
Cuando acabó la llamada me senté en mi despacho y miré por la ventana,
entre el shock y el vértigo.
Y entonces me di cuenta de que eso que había creado
tenía mucho más valor
que el que yo encontrara buenos guiones para leer en vacaciones.
Así que lo hice otra vez el año siguiente,
y el "LA Times" me destapó como la persona que la había creado,
y el año siguiente,
y el año siguiente... lo he hecho todos los años desde 2005.
Y los resultados han sido fascinantes,
porque, mentiras descaradas aparte, ese agente tenía toda la razón.
Para mucha gente, la lista era la prueba del valor del guion
y de que un guion tenía más valor
de lo que mucha gente, pienso, había anticipado.
Rápidamente, los escritores cuyos guiones estaban en la lista
empezaron a conseguir trabajos,
esos guiones empezaron a hacerse
y los guiones que se hacían
a menudo eran los que violaban las suposiciones
sobre lo que funcionaba y lo que no.
Había guiones como "Juno" y "Pequeña Miss Sunshine"
y "The Queen" y "El discurso del rey"
y "Spotlight".
Y sí, "Slumdog Millionaire"
E incluso una película próxima sobre el chimancé de Michael Jackson.
Creo que es muy importante que haga una pausa aquí un momento
para decir que el éxito de ninguna de esas películas es mérito mío.
Yo no las escribí, no las dirigí, no las produje, no las iluminé,
no preparé la comida ni el catering...
todos sabemos lo importante que es eso.
El crédito de esas películas, el crédito de ese éxito,
es de la gente que hizo las películas.
Yo lo que hice fue cambiar la forma en la que la gente las veía.
Accidentalmente pregunté si la sabiduría convencional era correcta.
Y obviamente hay películas en esa lista que se habrían hecho
sin la Lista negra,
pero hay muchas que desde luego no.
Como mínimo, hemos catalizado que se lleven a producción
y creo que es digno de mencionar.
Ha habido unos 1000 guiones en la Lista negra
desde que se descubrió en 2005.
Unos 325 han sido producidos.
Han sido nominados a 300 Oscars,
han ganado 50.
4 de las últimas 9 ediciones de "Mejores películas"
fueron para guiones de la Lista negra
y 10 de los últimos 20 Oscars de guiones han ido a guiones de la Lista negra.
Han recaudado USD 25 mil millones
en la taquilla mundial,
lo que significa que cientos de millones de personas
han visto estas películas fuera de sus casas,
se han sentado junto a alguien desconocido y se han apagado las luces.
Y eso sin decir nada de los entornos fuera del cine,
como el DVD, el streaming y, honestamente, las descargas ilegales.
Hace hoy cinco años, el 15 de octubre,
mi socio y yo reforzamos la idea
de que no ibamos a encontrar el talento de los guionistas donde pensábamos
y lanzamos una web que permitía que cualquier persona del mundo
que hubiera escrito un guion en inglés
lo subiera, fuera evaluado
y lo pusiera a disposición de miles de profesionales de la industria.
Y me alegra decir que en los cinco años desde que existe
hemos demostrado esa tesis con creces.
Cientos de escritores en el mundo han encontrado representantes,
han opcionado o vendido su trabajo.
7 se han convertido en películas en los últimos 3 años, incluyendo "Nightingale",
la historia del declive psicológico de un veterano,
en la que la cara de David Oyelowo es la única en pantalla
durante los 90 minutos que dura.
Fue nominada a un Globo de Oro y a dos premios Emmy.
También es genial que más de una docena de escritores
que fueron descubiertos en la web
han acabado en esta lista anual,
incluídos dos de los últimos tres escritores número uno.
Sencillamente, la sabiduría convencional sobre la calidad de los guiones,
dónde está y dónde se podía encontrar,
estaba equivocada.
Y esto es notable porque, como mencioné antes,
en el triaje de encontrar películas para hacer y hacerlas,
se confía mucho en la sabiduría convencional.
Y esa sabiduría convencional,
quizás y solo quizás
pueden estar equivocada con mayores consecuencias.
Las películas sobre negros no se venden en el extranjero.
Las películas de acción sobre mujeres no funcionan
porque las mujeres se verán en los hombres pero los hombres en las mujeres no.
Que nadie quiere ver películas sobre mujeres de más de 40 años.
Que nuestros héroes del cine tienen que ajustarse a una idea de belleza limitada
que consideramos convencional.
¿Qué significa cuando esas imágenes se proyectan a 9 metros de alto
y se apagan las luces,
para niños con mi aspecto en Columbus, Georgia?
¿O una niña musulmana en Cardiff, Gales?
¿O un niño gay en Madrás?
¿Qué dice de cómo nos vemos a nosotros mismos,
o de cómo vemos el mundo o cómo el mundo nos ve a nosotros?
Vivimos en un tiempo muy extraño.
Y creo que en la mayor parte vivimos en un estado de triaje constante.
Hay demasiada información,
demasiadas cosas contra las que pelear.
Y como norma, tendemos a usar la sabiduría convencional.
Y creo que es importante que nos preguntemos constantemente
¿cuánto de esa sabiduría convencional es convención y no sabiduría?
¿Y a qué precio?
Gracias.
(Aplausos)